we we we should be live we should be
live I don't know but we should be live
we should be live let me let me see
it's like and where
it is it is life will I okay it's like
and we we might be live
welcome to the attic show you guys where
we talk about the past present and
future again I got my clothes with me
Dirk griggity what's going on Dirk
what's up my man how you doing yeah
pretty good so uh I'm sure some of you
have noticed uh there's a little bit of
a change uh with the with the
presentation I'm messing around with it
okay like uh the background and stuff is
definitely going to change in the future
it's just I think I'm going to go with
this type of framework uh what what do
you think Dirk do you think it looks I
like it and I love the moves in the uh
background
yeah that that that's what I eat after
the podcast
see me just climb out of my little frame
and just shoot it
so what's going on you guys um you know
I appreciate it for coming through uh we
got a pretty good show for you guys
we're gonna talk about Starfield we're
also going to talk about this uh recore
you know this record rumor going around
which is interesting I don't know if
you've heard about that yeah go talk
about Xbox and Nintendo I I misspelled
Nintendo it's definitely an O addict I
don't know what you're doing there we're
talking Nintendo they got some little uh
thing going around and I uh it's
interesting how that's going to go and
I'm kind of curious to hear your opinion
on that uh but Dirk what's what's been
going on with you man what you've been
playing
well you know I've I've been taking
advantage of Xbox backwards
compatibility
like I told you last week I finished
Dead Space remake loved it so much it
made me want to go place play dead space
two and three
two was awesome three I'm playing it
right now it's okay it's not as good as
two and one but that's what I'm doing
I'm gonna um I booted up atomic heart
for a quick second last night it looks
great uh but I'm almost finished with
Dead Space 3 then I'm gonna get into
atomic heart and I'm still waiting for
Resident Evil next month and uh you know
Resident Evil uh
yeah I have a feeling Resident Evil is
going to be good
um
you know what I played it but I never
finished it I played it when it came to
the PS2
um but I never finished it I got like
halfway through but I I was enjoying it
but now
um I would say I'm a more mature gamer a
more patient gamer
Alice used to just like love action
games and you know like survival horror
games wasn't my thing back then but now
I absolutely love them
um so yeah I'm definitely going to
finish it because I finished you know
Resident Evil 2 remake incredible
resident number three remake was dope
also so yeah I'm definitely looking
forward to uh part four
yeah I think that you know when it comes
to stuff going on
um I like these remakes and I think that
they're doing a very good job at you
know pretty much redefining what a
remake truly is and absolutely I I enjoy
that I think that we need more of that
uh part of me feels like there for a
while remix was just something that they
would do it and they would do a very
very half and they wouldn't commit to
how I personally feel like they should
commit and now you you've seen like
Final Fantasy 7 remake uh the Resident
Evil franchise remakes you know you've
seen it with dead space uh you know
people these companies are showing look
we have no problem buying old games in
the mass because I never felt like you
ever heard of a remake doing like crazy
numbers it was always you know it's sold
okay but these newer remakes you're
hearing real numbers yeah and that's
what I like it's like look these get
these games can sell very well but you
actually have to put the time the money
and the effort if you wanted to do well
absolutely I agree with you as long as
the remakes makes sense like I still
don't agree with The Last of Us remake
but like a remake you know of an older
game it makes sense like if they remake
the original on Charlie the first
Uncharted that would be dope
that would be dope I hope they are
remaking that but there are some other
games I would love to see remix of
so I agree with you I Love the remix bro
even if it's a game that I played I
might not have played it I mean I played
it so long ago I kind of forgot it like
I finished Dead Space one
I I didn't remember a lot of stuff that
that happened in that game so dead space
remake was damn near like a new game for
me
yeah and I think that's the biggest
thing that we have to really consider is
we and to a point I feel like we're at
this point where maybe we need to have a
third tier that's a remastered remake
and I think maybe we need to have like a
reimagining tier two because there's
some games that
is a little bit different but I wouldn't
consider a remake and then there's some
games that is a remastered that I would
consider more of a remake like the Metro
Prime you know I think that's
technically a remake but is it and then
you know when it comes to Dead Space
they change some things around a dead
space but is that really a remake
you know what I consider a remake is
something like Final Fantasy VII where
they take the base game they expand on
the universe they make it better in all
way shapes or forms Resident Evil 4
we're seeing them drastically
overhauling that game to the point where
you're actually very you know very
different in a lot of scenarios but what
I've seen on Dead Space because I
haven't played the uh the Dead Space
remake is look look it's a fantastic
game a lot of people love it but it
looks to be just almost a one-to-one
with the original one listen I'm going
to tell you after I finished probably
one it made me want to go back and
compare
uh to the original
and I think you're right with their
space they did add some new stuff of
course like Isaac actually talks into
remake in the original he didn't talk in
in part one
um there are some different like there's
some slightly different things but at
the end of the day it's it's basically
the same game whereas the Resident Evil
franchise those part two and those are
remix bro those are complete remakes and
what you said I mean like you said what
they're doing part four that appears to
be a remake so I I agree with you
uh give me one second I gotta grab my
charger
yeah he has to grab a challenge ago well
my headset's about to die and uh let me
grab this charger real quick so it
doesn't die in the middle of the podcast
and I'm like the last thing I need is
just hearing it go off for no reason
hey yo bone slave I agree with that
master
um I'm sorry whatever in the Master
Chief Collection it was but I'm talking
about the Halo Championship Edition
I believe it started there when you like
you can switch from the old Graphics the
original Graphics to the update I
thought that was pretty dope
and and a Master Chief collection
um part two you can do that I believe
so that you see that's the stuff I love
man you know playing the older games and
and getting to experience them over with
uh like a FPS boost or something like
that because I want to tell you dead
space two and three still looks pretty
damn good they still look pretty good
there was a uh you know it was a like a
resolution upscale and the FPS boost so
part two part three still pretty damn
good man
do you think that
a lot of people don't like the way that
Dead Space 3 was a lot of people feel
like it was a little bit too too action
there's way more action than the
previous two yeah do you think that if
they've made let's say they go back and
they remake that space too and when they
eventually if that does well and they
remake Dead Space Three
do you think maybe they should touch up
certain aspects of the game yes because
their space three now
this is fresh in my mind because I
obviously just played them Dead Space 2
was freaking amazing it was in my
opinion a little bit better than one
part two was amazing part three they
just changed too much and they made it
more action like
my ammo like you have so much ammo on
part three I'm never I'm never like
nervous that I want to lose ammo in part
one or two you kind of damn my ammo's
getting low part three you have so much
ammo like it's like an action game it's
like a Call of Duty you're gonna have so
much ammo you're just shooting shooting
shooting so
part three yeah while it's still
graphically impressive to me
it's not as good as the game as as the
other two and if they did remakes for
the entire trilogy
um they will definitely have to touch up
part three make it a little bit more
Survivor horror and less action
I and if they don't do that they need to
make a lot of changes in the the base
came play like you know I feel like
there's a lot of aspects of dead space
that makes sense and then there's a lot
of aspects in that third one that didn't
like they they had a couple chapters in
death space three where it was like
dedicated to people going crazy and I
felt like you could do that just make it
different yeah and that's the big thing
yeah I already with the with the with
the smoke five dollar super trap from uh
uh mko 28 just seen dirt griggity's new
video about red dragon made me remember
I was still subbed in unsubbed all right
explain I saw that explain to me what's
going on with red dragon because I don't
keep up
well you know I don't want to do console
stuff on console war stuff on your
channel on the iron Lord's Channel but
what happened what made me do a video I
saw in this uh
this like almost an essay he he like
tweeted this long tweet
showing how much against the Activision
Blizzard deal he was he actually got
Twitter blue just so he can type 4 000
characters in one tweet and it was sad
to me man I don't know what Xbox did to
this guy I just really don't know why he
hate Xbox so much but he pretty much
just
in my eyes he was begging for them to
not allow this deal and you know he's
saying the same old stuff is going to
hurt the industry and
um you know less people will get to play
Call of Duty but obviously that's not
the case with the announcements from
yesterday which I'm sure we'll get to
later so that's that's I just did the
video about it saying you know why does
this guy hate Xbox so much because you
know I I used to be subscribed to him
back in the day I thought he was fair
um he was unbiased but all of a sudden
he just started just he goes on Twitter
and hate on Xbox all day so I just I was
just kind of confused about it so you
know when it comes to Red Dragon
I I wouldn't say that I still respect
red dragon because of like the content
creation he's done the past but I think
I'm more confused than anything with him
now because because sometimes it's just
like dude what like what are you talking
about
I didn't get it either very successful
YouTube channel over 120 000 subs and
I'm like I don't know bro I just I just
saw him on Twitter beef with the homie
Tim Dog like they were going back and
forth
and it's like it's like dude you better
than this like you're better than this
yeah I thought so too man
all right so it was a respectable
Channel like he was a a respectable
YouTube content creator and I don't know
what happened bro
yeah uh someone said dirt should be at
10K Subs right now there's a lot of
people I feel like put up way more
content and way better content than a
lot of the people that have bigger
followings uh but the the problem is is
we don't have people that have hundreds
of thousands of Subs constantly you know
sharing content constantly putting you
out there like it sucks man because you
see like people that grow
quick and then you always see them on
Twitter and stuff saying that they don't
like people that they talk they want
people to talk about games and stuff but
then you never see them sharing people
that make that kind of content yeah so
but but you see them in chats talking
about drama so it's like I don't know
but it is what it is yeah it definitely
go sub to Dart you know put your chat in
there man
I'm trying to get there fellas I'm an 8K
now I'm I'm trying to get there I'm
trying to I think IOP is about to hit
15. okay yeah it was uh it's been it's
been a struggle man because once where
the IOP Channel won't make regular
videos because that's the best way to
grow yeah it's hard to grow without that
constant video sock going out over and
over and that's why you see me reach out
to people like you know Cliff Cliffy B
and uh you know because even though that
there's a good chance they wouldn't come
on like I want to really put out there
it's like take your shot guys take your
shot because you'd be very surprised on
who is interested on coming on people
showing who who actually would take the
time to do it like you know I took that
shot of Cliffy B and you know it took a
little bit to get going because he you
know he's a busy dude and he he came on
you know uh same thing with Colin I know
a lot of people got issues with calling
but I took that shot and he's willing to
come on which you know I think I'm
I'm gonna because usually I just try to
keep it me and you I think the only
person I would actually put on here is
the third panelist member is probably
like kid smooth because I actually
enjoyed the The Chemistry Between all
three of us but I think I'm gonna try to
to bring more people on that you know
that we can bounce back off of uh that's
not in a toxic way you know what I'm
saying like because if there's one thing
that people say well get people always
tell me on the uh on IOP why don't you
guys have more PlayStation channels
because most of them are insane
like go ahead
and put in the chat PlayStation content
creators that don't console war fish 24
7.
and I'll be surprised if you can come up
with five
like it's that bad you know your people
could sit there like say they want about
the Xbox Community
um but there's a lot of content craze in
the Xbox community that just stick to
making Xbox content they don't talk
about PlayStation 24 7 but I see a lot
of the PlayStation content creators
they're only talking about Xbox they're
not a PlayStation content they're Xbox
content creators look at it like you
know I'm honest guy I clearly console
war stuff talk about PlayStation Fanboys
all day but like our guest last week
plume Network he's one guy
that's that's Pro Xbox and he doesn't do
console stuff on his channel he has a
quality Channel
there's one guy like somebody in the
chat said Mystic on the PlayStation side
he's he might be one of the only guys
that's a PlayStation Conti create I'm
actually though he's actually the only
PlayStation uh uh Focus channel that I'm
sub to because he doesn't console war he
he loves PlayStation but he doesn't go
out there bashing Xbox and I love his
content also you know what I'm saying so
there's a he's right the only one I can
think of I can't think of
I don't know man I can't really think of
any more
PlayStation Pro PlayStation channels
that that don't and you know Xbox all
day when it comes to every Fanboy got
their own little niche that annoys me I
feel like a lot of uh my famous toxic
positivity uh phrase I feel like a lot
of that resides in the Xbox Community
constantly uh you know hyping up stuff
we know nothing about or always trying
to turn something that is clearly a bad
thing sometimes if it smells like [__]
and tastes like [__] and [__] but they
they want to spray like Febreze on and
say it doesn't smell or taste it so you
know it is what it is uh Still Loving to
death but I do feel like they'd be
capping so uh so it is what it is on
that and I just feel like PlayStation uh
you know a lot of PlayStation Fanboys
they're just they're just so tall
anything even remotely positive about
Xbox they lose they mind they like they
do it
is people just gonna like
why do people have these loud speakers
that have nothing to do with what's
going on I'm constant because it's
starting to get a little hot so I like
keeping my window open but geez when
you're doing these podcasts and my
windows right here like I'm here Windows
right here and they gotta put them
sounds they pumping them sounds
yeah it is what's funny is they just
turn around they even come in they
didn't even like park in the parking lot
so I don't know they just did though
yeah so all right let's go ahead and get
on with the with the show man you know
we obviously we got to do our little you
know talk talk at the beginning we got
to get up a little bit going on there so
dirt
is that
is that thunder man I said it was a hell
of a thunder in my um
I'm sorry about that I was listening
it's not somebody stomping upstairs a
little Thunder I'm sorry about that I
know you guys couldn't hear it but it
kind of scared the hell out of me for a
second yeah so all right let's talk
about
this star filled reveal uh apparently
it's been highly rumored you have people
like jazz ran you know Cole I was told
something was supposed to happen last
week but something it seems like
announcement pushed back yes like some
form of announcement was supposed to
happen last week but it does seem like
it was pushed back
um what I want from you is you know when
do you think this event because we have
talked about it before uh but I think we
kind of thought it was gonna happen this
month like the announcement at least was
gonna happen this month but now we're
getting into the point where like
the further it gets pushed back
do you think that there's more and more
of a chance that this might come out
later of 2023 and not in the first six
months like we do
um
no I think it will be out in the first
six months because you know well you say
you you heard some things uh you said
Jess said he heard some things I saw Tim
Dog say some stuff
on Twitter today saying um something
maybe something will be announced Monday
maybe
um so I you know is that the point
obviously I don't know I don't have any
inside information but I think
that the Starfield will be out
um supposedly by June hopefully by June
yeah I don't think they're going to
postpone it to the second half or I
think the game is in a polishing phase
and I I believe they they really want to
get this game out before June
um so hopefully you know I don't know if
it'll be later June or or before E3 but
I really do think that this event will
be announced soon now
you said before the end of the month
well Monday is still the 27th
still a couple more days in a month so
you know it's definitely possible they
can announce the show soon
I I think that you know it's one of
those things where
you know I I just I want to hear
something you know what I'm saying like
I just get so frustrated with no info
and it's like the one thing everyone
wants to hear is like the one thing no
one ever talks about and I think that's
the biggest thing that's frustrating
because it's like I want to see this I I
don't want no more of this all you know
addict it will be here okay that's Q
that's cute
I'm on I'm at the point where I I don't
want to talk about I want to see it and
this is something like I'm very big on
with this game like Starfield and it
just feels like I keep more and more it
feels like I have to wait longer and
longer
and it's it's frustrating man it's
really frustrating
yeah I mean I understand but I think you
know you know it's almost there Eddie
it's almost there buddy
one day one day it's just gonna show up
and you know I do you still think this
might hit that six months or do you
think we're at this point where it's
probably a holiday game
I think it's going to hit the six months
because um
part of me still thinks hellblade 2 was
dropping this year and I don't think
they want to drop those in in the same
you know
in the same area
uh but uh because somebody in my chat
yesterday said hey man
to me in his own vacation
I think the game is done I said he's on
vacation
does that mean the game is almost ready
or is he just on vacation but he used to
lead them Ninja Theory so I'm like hmm
does that mean
it's close to being finished so I think
he'll play too dropping this year so I'm
still thinking Starfield is the first
half
it'd be very interesting if that happens
because I think
that a lot of people they just they just
want to see it you know it's like me I
understand that you know people get
upset that we get so hyped for this game
and and it's just like
coming from someone like me I'm a huge
I'm a huge Elder Scrolls fan I love
those I love the old Fallout games and
to me it's just like I just want to see
it yo I'm not I'm not I'm not even at
this point where
I want to like see everything it's just
like at least just show me that you know
what I'm saying
you say you ready to see you know I get
it um I get it I mean at this point
though like how much longer
is
how much longer are we going to keep
going
without seeing that I think that's where
I'm at it's just like you know I was
very big on wanting to see the game when
we did that event and we didn't do it we
didn't get it and that's like one of the
biggest things like sure a lot of people
are hyped for redfall you know and I
think Hi-Fi Rush did what it was
supposed to I think it stole the show
and it was the talk of the internet for
for a while but I think at the end of
the day we can all agree that what
people want what people truly want is
that Starfield gameplay
yeah I think Xbox knows that I think
that's why they say they're going to
have their own event for it
um because Starfield is a massive game
that deserves its own event
and it's gonna be cool bro
so it's a little bit more what is your
expectations
I'm expecting Starfield
you know like to be specific I'm just
expecting hours and hours of gameplay
I'm expecting a Bethesda game obviously
but I'm expecting a little more polish
Bethesda game because
we've seen highlight Bethesda games in
the past have released buggy and like
like some people still don't care they
love their games
now I'm expecting the more polish I'm
not saying it's going to be bug free but
I'm I'm expecting a more polished game
and I'm expecting a game that will be
created critically acclaimed
I'm expecting Starfield to be in the
Game of the Year nominees nominations
that's what I'm expecting um I said I
believe Todd Howard feel experience in
the Xbox knows how important this game
is to Bethesda to Xbox to to the brand
and they will make sure the game is
right where it needs to be this is my
opinion if they needed like if they
needed the extra time obviously couldn't
drop it last year okay gave them extra
time I think they're I think they're
ready for it and I think the game's
gonna be quality
you know be crazy man it's like I said
I'm curious to see how some of these
people they're like highly negative on
anything Xbox does how they're gonna
handle
if
we get
hellblade huge success 90 plus let's say
a hellblade
Starfield all 90 pluses and redfall is
an 80 plus
like it enforces like an 85 Plus
yeah and don't forget Hi-Fi Rush is
already 88.
right
you know what those things what you're
saying is possible at it
that's not far-fetched like that's not
in the possible statement that you made
like you know there's not there's
nowhere in hell that's going to happen
no that's definitely possible bro
I just want you know at this point
I just want it I want
to see Xbox do well
and I think there's a lot of
stuff that goes on
that it just makes me feel like you know
if we could finally have
that solid foundation for Microsoft and
where they're actually pumping out you
know pretty good games and we have it
with with Sony like that is such a good
foundation for gaming where it doesn't
matter where you play you could see good
games
yeah I think that um Phil Spencer
remember
Crackdown three and static K2 and see if
these and the jokes that was being made
last generation
um you know with the Xbox only makes 60
meta created games and you know they
were like the PlayStation guys were
talking a lot of trash the media was
saying Xbox needs to step up the quality
of their games
Phil Spencer pay attention to that bro
you know he does
Xbox themselves pay attention to all of
that stuff and they want to change that
perception they have already changed
this generation if you want to be honest
2021 day one publisher of the year I
know people didn't give them credit
soccer Notch two is not their game
but look they want it
what can we say so I think um the
quality and the quality is very very
important to Microsoft
and that's what it's about to be man I
think it's our time
you want to be honest I get tired of
that that
statement from people well this is not
their game that's not their game final
fantasy is not PlayStation's game but I
never not take that from them right you
know and the funny thing is like people
will try to sit there and say
starfield's not Microsoft you know
technically they own it but I need you
to see what what Bethesda does under a
Microsoft budget I'm like
that makes no sense so we're just going
to go from making good games to bad
games like on the Fly Like that's my
issue like I can understand if you if
you're skeptical on on developers that
haven't really delivered yeah but we're
gonna sit here and act like obsidian
ain't gonna just start they're gonna
just start making horrible games right I
don't believe that I came about to start
making terrible games no yeah I think
for the most part anyone saying that
that they they're fooling themselves at
that point
I agree with you man I wholeheartedly
agree like you said obsidian is known
for making great games
they're not going to stop now hell
they're probably going to get better
because they have Microsoft behind them
bigger budgets
so I agree with you man when people see
that that goes what you said um there
are some people that just hate Xbox they
hunt they constantly
flip the narrative move the goal post or
however you want to put it you know we
went from Xbox needs some new IP
Xbox needs some new games Xbox needs
this too those aren't Xbox games
star field is not an Xbox game okay
so watch what happens later when there's
a like where fall there's a willow gangs
is in development before Xbox 2 was in
development before I bought them so that
goes to what you said Us Xbox guys we
will sit here and give PlayStation
credit
I love God of War those games are great
they won't do that bro
they will try to find a reason to not
give them credit
and you heard of this generation organic
growth
right organic growth those are not Xbox
games you know I think that was like the
biggest funny thing ever
it's like people arguing organic growth
and it's like you know pick your battle
because sometimes that battle ain't
gonna win
absolutely pick your battle
all right so you know I think uh you
know for the most part we we done with
that conversation
I ain't really a whole lot to have with
that you know I think at this point I
think you can even agree
show up or shut up you know we don't
want to see Starfield again until it's
ready for a release date I think uh
that's one of the biggest things even
they went out there and showed me a
bunch of gameplay I'm still gonna be
scratching my head and like okay that's
funny where is the release date yeah you
know when am I playing this game and I
think people just want to see that
because at this point
Microsoft bought these Studios so long
ago that that is one of the biggest
question are they going to use these
Studios and do what's right and I think
that's the biggest question people have
yeah I think Microsoft knows that though
um so the next time they show I start
feel I I believe they will show a lot of
gameplay and they will announce the
release date
all right so let's move on to recore you
know there's been a lot of stuff going
on we got 30 minutes and 10 seconds for
the uh the time stamp Mafia you know uh
I will avoid the six feet under for for
another week well first off did you beat
recore yes
I'm the only person I know that beat
record I beat record oh so you're the
second person I know the beat record
yeah I'd be recording first off give me
overall impressions of recore I'm
curious I love record bro um
the franchise has so much potential a
you can tell it was a double A like it
was a lower budget game made on the
unity engine you can kind of tell
but when it comes to the character her
relationship with with with like the
robots
um like the story I mean like it wasn't
much story but I just love the the the
gameplay I love how certain areas you
know you need certain robots
the platforming
I just don't think that game got enough
credit for some of the platforming that
that you have to do especially later in
the game oh my God some of that stuff I
couldn't believe I passed it afterwards
it was it was crazy man yeah the
platforming in the in the last Tower of
the game is
some of the most
annoying unique platforming I've ever
seen in a video game
and annoying and unique yeah and I don't
think people give them enough credit for
that you know where it's easy to break a
game down
I don't see as many people giving it
props for what it did do or even Give
opinions on what they could have done
better
right I agree
um you know like
the open world wasn't really you know
much there's this this sand just a
desert
the graphics wasn't amazing but I
thought the gameplay was solid like I
said the platforming was amazing just
the the overalls
uh concept of the game I love and I feel
this franchise has so much potential so
when the game didn't really do that well
it had a low Metacritic I was like damn
I was wishing this game could be
you know be be better because that main
character and and all of her robots that
stuff man that's that's some great stuff
so I just wish the game could come back
and
what's happening attic is there a little
tease or something
apparently there was some uh
there was like
some update on Twitter or something do
you know a hundred percent of the the
stuff going on
no I saw something
um that what was the name of the studio
Armature
amateur
they posted on the official recore
Twitter
and this is the first time anybody has
posted anything on that Twitter in the
Years
they posted something with a whole bunch
of words and stuff I don't know if it
was even real words from what I saw
and people say hold on man they actually
posted something on official recore
Twitter
hmm
mate is making people you know talk like
what does that mean like what's going on
with recore
foreign
that is interesting because if you think
about it
you know even if
I'm getting a little annoyed
that people are starting to do stuff
like that and then they kind of get they
get upset if you
expect something well hold up let me let
me think of why I want to say this
all right people get annoyed what let's
say that I
post on there I'm like look you know
it's been rumored that this is coming
out like there's a new thing now where
people get upset with people just
talking about rumors
um and it's like that's literally my job
right that's literally the content
Creator's job to talk about all the
latest stuff going on in the industry
and the funny thing is just like I just
don't understand
why do you think maybe it's because
people just don't like this game do you
think maybe that's it like to
immediately say why are you talking
about rumors and stuff
you know honestly I can tell that record
wasn't for everybody
um because you know like you had to find
a bunch of those cores to get to the
Tower and I don't think people really
understood how to do that yeah they
should have did that a lot better like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you could
tell the game wasn't ready when it came
out because if you look at the cover of
the game
the robot that's on wheels
he's on the cover of the game but he's
not in the game not in the game until
they made the definitive The Definitive
Edition a year later
so that tells you right there the game
wasn't ready but at that time Xbox
needed games
and some of the games they had to rush
out like recore like a sea of Thieves
they had to rush out State Decay too
they had to rush those games out when it
wasn't really finished because Xbox
needed some type of content
and that's what they did
I want this game I I really because
um I have gameplay in the background
um yeah
I really want this to be true like I
can't I can't vocalize enough I've said
it a couple times I truly believe
that a well done recore
could be
just as big as like ratchet and cling
uh you know I get it you know they kind
of dropped the ball in a lot of
different ways
uh but I I refuse to believe that this
game can't do well I refuse to believe
you know I think that people don't want
it to do well they they want it to
automatically say that it's not good but
I do feel like recore has the potential
to be a great franchise as long as it's
correctly supported and and keep in mind
what I just said correctly supported
because I feel like a lot of people
don't understand that
just because a game gets greenlit
doesn't mean it was supported during the
time that was taken it was taken to be
made
I agree mom hey you know I think Delilah
HD she also beat record if I'm not
mistaken she's a third person at beating
so we all have that similar type of love
for the record and felt it was slept on
um you know and just overlooked listen
I'm not going to say the game was
flawless
but it was something about this game
that I absolutely love man
and if if they if this is true and
they're putting more money into the
franchise
I love it because like I said earlier I
believe this franchise has tons of
potential and you say if it's done right
it could be
it could be the their
type of platforming thing like all right
let's let's let's let's go down dirt
Let's Get Down in the trenches what what
do you think needs to improve the most
on recore
um story
I believe the graphics need to improve
it needs to be a showcase a very
beautiful looking guy yeah like if it
had some Horizon forbidden West type of
Graphics oh my God you know
um yeah but that's that's two things
that I I believe that really needs to
improve
um a better way okay if you I would love
to be able to choose your robots on the
Fly because there were some missions
where you needed specific robots and you
had to kind of go back to to like uh
your um checkpoint or whatever you call
it
your hood or whatever you call it that's
something they should fix if you you
know used to be able to switch your I
mean to uh change your robots on the Fly
I would like that maybe with the d-pad
up down left right so that's something I
would like to and also you know like the
there the the the desert was pretty
barren
you know but they can fix that in the
sequel if this is true
it'll be really funny if a recourse did
would you prefer them to make a sequel
or reboot record and like restart it I
will prefer to make a sequel
and
well they rebooted no I would just want
a sequel and just be everything that the
developers wanted the first game to be
get off on uh Unity use another engine I
mean because you know it is a Quality
Engine but it's not really a triple A
engine
yeah
yeah exactly I would love just a big
AAA version of record bro and it's kind
of weird that it was made on Unity like
being backed by Microsoft
maybe that was like a like
well you know that was during those
times man you know during those times
that we're not supposed to talk about
when the xBox wasn't really investing in
first party if the game was not Halo
gears or Forza or you know game that was
already in development that was during
those those years right
I if if I were a person what I would
want from from this game is uh first
thing I want them to do is focus on
redefining the platforming that because
I feel like it needs to be on the game
needs to be on three pillars platforming
unique combat that they have now just
you know really tighten the combat up
give it a little bit more depth and make
it look gorgeous yeah and I think you
put those three with some good not even
like amazing storytelling just good
storytelling uh you you would keep
people up because I feel like there's
levels to storytelling that you got
stuff like Last of Us I think that is
like amazing storytelling uh then you
got games like God of War which I think
is is good storytelling but the gameplay
really covers the rest that that doesn't
do and I think you would have it man I
really truly think that that is
something that if Microsoft put money
behind that it would do it and the fact
that they're responding any way shape or
form is just weird because one will
think this game would be dead there's no
reason to even law log into that account
but I I remember
I made a video that
the person who played the the actual uh
main character of record I can't
remember her name
yeah I know you're talking about that
and I think I know what you're about to
say that and she was
she was uh there was pictures taken to
her in a mocap suit I saw that yeah oh
yeah it was a long time ago so you'll be
crazy if E3 they announced recour too
and it's coming out this year
they've been making record this entire
time
remember that was around 20 what 18 2017
when like she was in a mo capsule
because I remember that
yeah I I remember exactly where I lived
I made a video about it
uh yeah I I think I think it's a good
thing I think people need to really try
this game and I get it
the the core finding thing was annoying
and they kind of fixed it a little bit
there uh with an update but by then a
lot of people dropped the game and I
think that the court finding it I was
the issue the visualization of it
needed to be redefined too because
unfortunately these days if you want to
grab a huge massive Community you got to
have the game looking really really nice
because that's what people see the game
could have the best gameplay in the
world but if that game doesn't visually
look nice or at least average
people will tend to not gravitate
towards it as much and I think that's
why it's extremely important Fable looks
nice it's extremely important the
hellblade looks nice these games if you
want to have that God of war effect
which is funny I'm looking at this here
this never happened I don't remember
like the robots grabbing each other like
that yeah
so I mean
that's that's possible stuff they have
to leave on the uh uh uh what you call
it the Cutting Room floor I'd love to
get a interview with every Court
developer and you know it would be
interesting if I reached out to get an
interview developer and they couldn't
comment on anything
oh because then that that's that's
interesting because that either you got
an NDA
for when you worked on record that
somehow have lasted this long which is
unheard of
or you're working on a newer project
that is recore
inspired or something recore like and
you can't comment on it so either way I
win
so it's interesting man it's interesting
uh do you think the combat needs to
improve like drastically or do you think
that you know for as simplistic as it
was I do think there needs to be a
little bit more depth in it it was
definitely simplistic
um more variety because you notice the
color coordinating oh yeah press the red
button for these this fold press the
blue one for this one yeah
a little bit more
variety maybe you know add some melee
and with with Close Encounters
you know just you know just just my
opinion so yeah I I agree with that I
agree with that they there definitely
needs to be a little bit more variety
yeah I agree with you on that and
Delilah said that the uh the platform
was already good uh it's not that I
think it was bad I just think it at this
point it needs to be redefined a little
bit you know uh the platforming was
fantastic especially you know when
you're in that Tower at the end of the
game that's some of the hardest
platforms I've ever did in a video with
the red laser yes there'd be sometimes
where they they demand you to fall below
lasers
to jump up to go above the lasers and it
was very frustrating that took me a few
times yeah yeah you know what because
smooth beat it too and I remember being
in a party was smooth and I don't know
if you've ever been in the Xbox Live
party with smooth uh but
he he just he loses his he loses it like
he he the moment smooth is is put in a
challenge where he feels like he can't
prevail
he just loses his mind like and it's the
funniest thing in the world to hear him
struggle but at the same time like man
yeah your blood pressure too high man
your blood pressure way too hot because
you've seen him like flip out like on
Twitter and stuff imagine that but on
another level like another level and
that's smooth
the funniest thing to this day was when
um in 2018 when Xbox announced Ninja
Theory that they bought Ninja Theory
and smooth ah
yeah I was in that I was in that yeah
there was a little bit above ahead of me
and I kept telling them over and I'm
like dude shut up like I'm trying to
hear it like you're ruining my
experience smooth
all right so let's let's go ahead and um
let's talk let's talk talk to the paper
man you know there's a lot of stuff
going on right now uh I'm getting rid of
uh the thing I was doing right there
Nintendo Nintendo and Microsoft look
like they actually might be working on
something uh together in some way shape
or form uh you know I I don't know how
in-depth this is to be honest with you
uh I just saw the initial statement uh
you know but what what is your uh
responses you know let's go over a
little bit on what the statement was as
well there's a lot of stuff that was
going on
yeah um
initially people thought the brass Smith
was kind of saying that all Xbox games
will go no I read it like four times and
I'm like I don't understand how people
like got that out of that well well you
know how people interpret things with
Xbox
um even Brad Smith himself said in the
interview no it's just about Call of
Duty right now um listen man I think
Xbox is doing what they have to do
putting
signing a 10-year deal with Nintendo
means
listen we're putting the game
on other platforms signing a deal with
Nvidia same thing they're putting the
game on other platforms look CMA look EU
look FTC excuse me we're not taking the
game away
we're actually putting it on other
platforms and like Brad Smith said
if you add Nintendo and Nvidia
that's 150 million people
that's 150 million more people with that
could play Call of Duty or whatever game
so
Xbox is doing this because I don't think
Nintendo really cares about Call of Duty
Xbox offered it they say okay fine yeah
we'll sign the deal because Nintendo has
survived all of these years without Call
of Duty I don't think they care about it
like that but it's but it's better to
have it and and and need it than a needy
and not have it right
so
that's how I feel about I feel that Xbox
is doing this deal not just but like hey
man Nintendo you're our buddy
they're trying to get this deal done and
put it in on a Nintendo switch will help
their case that's just my opinion
all right so
let me
let me go ahead and bring up uh
the screen in general it's going to be
above us we're not going to be in the in
the video uh but I do want to go over
this this statement
uh right here so Microsoft and Nintendo
have now renegotiated and signed a
binding 10-year legal agreement to bring
Call of Duty to Nintendo players the
same day as Xbox with full features and
content parity so they can experience
Call of Duty Justice PlayStation and
Xbox Gamers enjoy Call of Duty we are
committed to providing long-term equal
access to Call of Duty to other plot
gaming platforms bringing more Market to
uh more Choice tomorrow Mark oh my God
to bring more choice to more players and
more competition in the gaming Market
all right so
here's my thing
the funny thing
is Microsoft making agreements acting
like they already own Call of Duty you
know what I'm saying like it's like
okay I didn't even think you could
remember how
huh they're binding contracts
I get that Bethesda like when they
bought Bethesda they didn't want to
comment on anything they were going to
do with their brands afterwards true
they're like we can't do it until we
officially own it and I feel like here
they're like look they're just saying
this is what we're going to do this is
what our intentions and it's like what
was the difference between Bethesda and
Activision a lot of money yeah that and
also uh the but there's the there wasn't
ever scrutinized like this deal like we
didn't hear anything about the deal
being scrutinized publicly
this deal is way more money
and also
um you're hearing a lot of you know
pushback
like from Sony
from FTC you know from from different
Regulators you didn't hear anything
about any pushback hell like the
Bethesda deal they announced it in
September of 2020 the deal was finalized
around was in March of 2021
it didn't take long at all this deal is
a little different so I believe
The Mindy contracts is something that
Xbox is talking about
because I'm sure they might have had
some type of contrast binding contracts
with the Bethesda deal but they just
didn't talk about it but with this one
they're talking about it they're putting
it out there right look guys we're
offering Nintendo this we're offering
Nvidia this
this binding contract because we want to
make sure Call of Duty is still played
by millions of people we're actually
adding additional people than what it
was before this we're going to offer the
same deal to Sony now if they're taking
if they take it or not that's up to them
but we're going to offer this same deal
to them which Brad Smith said yesterday
in his opinion is a better deal
than what they currently have now
because PlayStation deal ends in 2024.
so this is an extra 10 years so I think
um this is a a different case it's a
more it's a much bigger case so that's
why things are going a little different
I feel you I think my mindset is they
could have said more on the Bethesda
thing and they chose not to because they
have because they weren't getting really
uh you know under the microscope as much
as they are now because to me if
uh you know the FTC and them came up and
they're like yo we ain't letting this
Bethesda deal you would have the same
stuff going on now then oh you know
we're gonna let this I don't know do you
think that because that wasn't as much
that maybe Microsoft if they got under
the same thing they would have just like
okay we're not buying Bethesda then
huh well because I feel like Call of
Duty is the reason they're willing to
let all this aside
it's worth it yeah it's it's worth it
because Sony wouldn't push back I don't
think about Fallout or Elder Scrolls
Sony is a big part of this
um and Call of Duty is literally the
best selling game every year so I think
that's pretty much what's causing so
much pushback
if this Bethesda deal was being
scrutinized like this activism blizzard
deal
I mean I'm sure Xbox would have fought
for it
but like you mentioned seven billion as
compared to 70 billion
I think
Call of Duty and activism blizzard means
a little bit more because it's not just
Call of Duty uh or console PC games is
also mobile
so this deal means a lot to them because
Xbox Microsoft has to say
want something to do with mobile gaming
because it's huge and actually buying
King is a big move so that means a lot
to them also
do you feel like if they were given a
position where they can own Activision
but they have to spin off Call of Duty
to its own company uh do you think they
would do that
and Brad Smith already said hell no you
said that makes no sense I feel like
they want it for everything they don't
want it for just one thing and there are
some things I think they would like
slide like certain things like I mean
hell they they let uh you know QA teams
in Activision form a
uh a union without really saying much
and I know they don't have a whole lot
of control over that right now uh but to
me stuff like that happening before you
buy it would definitely change if you
would want it or not depending on
Microsoft's stance on unions right so
the fact that they were just letting
that happen means that they want this
bad like it wasn't really bad they do 70
billion they want it bad I I just feel
that they feel that gaming is huge in
particular Mobile gaming Call of Duty is
the biggest game out there
that being under Microsoft's umbrella
means a lot
um and I feel this they really want this
deal bro you see bruh
they're they're meeting listen Brad
Smith was out there he's like a pit bull
man he he pulled off the contracts here
yo this is the contract we offer Sony
this is the damn contract they don't
want to sign it they want this deal at
it like you said you can tell
you can tell they want this deal man and
it means a lot to them
you know when this Activision first
thing happened I'll say exactly what I
said then I don't really care
I'm not the biggest fan of the universe
that they have built in anything I don't
really care about most Activision games
an entirely in an entire entirety I do
feel like there's some things there that
would be interesting I personally feel
like we need to see more combined
universes
that's going on like I think it would be
cool if you made like a universe where
if you buy them you own crash and you
own spiral
it's like you already have banjo
and they all have similar art styles
maybe not exact but similar so it's like
make them in their own universe
like you know put crash and and maybe uh
spire on the same game and then you know
put in the the lore that that they're in
the same universe as Banjo-Kazooie in
another part of the world or something
yeah I I think there's a lot that you
can do that I feel like that's not done
as much you know you have stuff like the
MCU that does really well because they
build on these building blocks
of these characters and they keep
building on top of them forcing the
people that want to keep up with it to
continue doing it we gotta find all the
Superstar from Dave Ramos Playing
devil's advocate AV uh adk could uh
bring Cod to switch without Xbox and
still reach 100 million Gamers agreement
by uh White Knight Microsoft is
self-serving
what are you talking about I have no
clue what he's talking about Call of
Duty hasn't been on Nintendo since what
the Wii U
yeah it I it that's like the mindset
that some of these people be having
sometimes make no sense
it's like we we can do one without the
other like you don't need to to publicly
Bash one thing to get another thing
where you want it like we could do it
all and
that's that's where I'm like talking
about more unique stuff because I'm
tired is it just me or is game starting
to become Bland like the same thing over
and over again you get unique
experiences every now and then but I do
feel like there's a lot of the same type
of games now
yeah but see see that's because there's
a
lot of these companies
they're just scared to take a risk at it
they're scared bro I get it and I think
a lot of that's to do with like the
wrong risk can can cost you everything
yeah but at the same time same time
sometimes you have to make these risks
to be ahead of your competition
yeah phones I want you on the show again
man you got to hit me up when you got
time I love when Fonz is a unique person
that that I love to pick his brain gotta
find out from the angry therapist would
love to see Doom guy in Diablo that
would be interesting yeah that'd be cool
but I think
doomguy makes more sense but Doom guy
feels like to me like more of a main
person you know what I'm saying and I
feel like dude fighting Doom fighting
some of those demons I don't know like
do you think that Doom can can like
Clash with like Diablo and angels and
[__]
I don't I don't know I think they don't
have guns guns in Diablo do they do they
have guns in Diablo I can't remember I
would actually like to see Dune guy and
Master Chief in a game
oh man goon guy he's but he's like
badass man like because you know I I
think that Doom like Master Chief
obviously I don't think he could take
Doom God I think Doom God would just
destroy Master Chief Doom guys bad ass
bro
it would determine on if Doom guy
can penetrates pause can penetrate
um Master Chief's armor because that's
that's not easy to get through
I think that would be the ultimate
Factor if they could fight like that
um
uh yeah but I don't know man Chief is
cool Doom guys badass over he don't even
talk he just kills you know I'm saying
Doom guy ain't no joke man speaking of
Doom doommy Turner came out with 2021
right or 2020. 00
yeah they should be close to having
another game close to their next
announcement bro
yeah that would be interesting I wish
they would do more crossovers like you
gotta five dollar Super Chat from uh
rubber knob
uh Call of Duty won't work on the switch
without xcloud also do you think Game
Pass is coming to the Nintendo platform
I I wouldn't be surprised maybe there's
some talks like that going on right now
where you know
you can buy it on there but they're like
or we can give you Game Pass I don't
know here's the thing even if this
happens is it gonna run good like is it
gonna even be feasible remember when
fortnite came out and a shirt it was on
the switch but it was 30 frames
and they
they eventually made it to where
they stopped having them in the same
pool as the other console like they kind
of unbinded them
yeah yeah they did that with the WWE 2K
series I remember it came out the same
year maybe 2017 and it was terrible they
couldn't fix and they never made another
one for the switch but this Cod deal can
also be for the next wish because that
has to be coming next year right at
least right
one would hope you would think right you
would think Nintendo switch will come
out next year or something we got we got
a uh a member chat a member for 18
months man Lord Silva got Donna taku
Nintendo Don dahotaku why do y'all just
forget that Nintendo has another console
dropping in the next two years
I just mentioned that bro yeah I agree
with you I agree with you because this
would be part of the Super Chat was
before we got into that conversation I
don't know I I feel like
I feel like even
if they did a switch Pro 2 because I
don't think they're going to go back to
traditional console making I think
they'd be very foolish to do that I I
highly doubt that's on the agenda but I
would be very curious to see how
because one of the reasons that it does
so well is because they're able to make
a handheld that can function on a dog
can function without a dog
I'm curious
how much they can because they can't
have it too high
but at the same time they don't want to
they don't want to get
overshot either you know they don't want
to make a a platform that's already weak
when it comes out and then you know you
know maybe maybe PlayStation I mean
maybe Nintendo don't care
maybe they're like I don't think they
care bro I I think the next switch might
be to the same power I wouldn't know man
that's the PS4 or something you know I I
just think that Nintendo doesn't care
they're next they're being very careful
with their next console bro
because we say this before you know we
talk about this all the time
the Nintendo Wii 104 million console
sold
the Nintendo switch is at 122 and the
Wii U was at 13.
bro they are trying to be very very
careful with their next console they
want to make sure it's done right
because they do not want a repeat of the
Wii U
H money or 104 million to 13 is crazy
and plus what I would want and I know
they would never do this uh but I think
we could all agree that a lot of their
key components to traveling playing
games on the go is they're they're
Nintendo games the stuff they make and I
think I would want them to do a
a kind of a hybrid where you you travel
with it but I would also like that doc
to pretty much like when you put it in
the dock it actually can play games at a
reasonable output so for instance let's
say because that's I think that's the
way it was originally intended to be but
it never got that I feel like there was
some way shape or form that you know at
the beginning you was seeing a little
bit of bump in frame rate and a bump in
and everything but then what ended up
happening was
it kind of slowly lost that grass where
these games are running so bad on the
switch
putting them in docks not helping
and I would want a thing because there's
a lot of games that don't come out for
Nintendo
and I have my own personal beliefs in
that and I know a lot of people don't
believe in it
but I personally feel like they like it
that way they like these games not
coming out because what happens when
they do that
what happens when these games don't run
good on the switch so they don't have
games like Call of Duty games like The
Witcher sure they can get money for
those games but there's nothing
competing with Splatoon
right you you buy some platoon or you
don't play multiplayer games right you
buy their multiplayer games because
guess what there's not third-party
multiplayer games cannibalizing their
own games
and I think that's helped them more than
anything and people I remember being
Forte I got an argument on that hey
shout out to the 281 people when you hit
that like button guys get that up there
as much as you can man I want to see
that over 150 likes before uh the show
ends I know that's probably not going to
happen I'll be very surprised if it did
but to get that up there man let's get
that over 100 at least it's two likes
there's two of you in this chat that
ain't like that podcast they can get
that over two two man there you go 99 we
almost there guys we need one more there
you go thank you uh we got a we got a
member chat from Fawn saying attic
what's your thoughts on the next switch
being completely All Digital I think
they'll end up going that route I don't
uh Nintendo's been very vocal about
having switch games
about having uh uh physical gains
because it's easier to do stuff like
that
um so then we got final Superstar from
the amazing nail kitsu this funny guy
please bring him on more shout out to
Dart G and the TTS crew what's up
amazing Neil
yeah buddy I'd like to get a smooth on
here like my dream pattern would be me
dark and smooth I feel like we have good
chemistry jokes back and forth sure I
couldn't control them on the console war
thing at that point you know I think
they they definitely pan that stuff back
because it's my truck but at that point
it is what it is like
yeah but I do you think that Nintendo
will go all digital
um not yet
then again who knows man Nintendo do
what the hell they want
and people either accept it or they
don't
um
I don't think so but then again who
knows bro like
if the new Nintendo game I mean console
comes out next year
I I think next year would be two
um too early to fully Go All Digital
without an uh
oh you know what you know what it might
be all digital but they might have a
separate disk drive
that's that's additional that's
additional money
what happens if the handheld is digital
only but when you put it in the dock
that has the physical portion of it
um
so you're saying the doc has the
physical disc disk drive
like that makes what I want is the dock
to be pretty much an extension not just
something to project your your console
onto it like I know uh Donald talk who's
in there saying you know uh the only
thing we care about uh resolution isn't
important I'm not saying resolution is
important on on you know switch but you
could definitely tell a difference when
you play a modern game on like an Xbox
PC or PlayStation and you see you know
that resolution pop that HDR pop and you
go play uh you know fire emblem for the
switch you can't tell me there's not a
difference because there is I just beat
fire emblem not too long ago and there
was clearly a difference
yeah
I agree and I think the reason that
we're not seeing as much comparison
between the platforms is because there's
not a lot of games that's on the switch
that's also on the other platforms a lot
of the stuff that comes from the switch
is either the Indie Games some second
party that happens to come over that
doesn't really need much to run it or
it's first party Nintendo stuff which
doesn't go anywhere but that platform
yep
I agree sir
so yeah I think that that's that's
that's about you know real quick before
we before we end the show though uh what
what's what's your opinion on what's
your games that you're looking forward
to this year man I'm kind of curious
what's the game that's you want to play
like I said Resident Evil before
looks somewhere looks so good looks so
good
actually WWE 2K 20
3 I'm looking forward to that
um I like last year versions this one
looks good also
of course Starfield red fall
no Forza
I'm definitely looking forward to those
games
I'm more hyped than for rarefall than
anything as far as Xbox first party
um there are some other multi-platform
games I'm trying to think
help me out a little bit brother
um obviously I'm looking for for the
Starfield
um I'm really let me let me look at the
games that's officially slated to come
out this year
yeah there's there's a game I can't
remember but I remember being hyped for
it
there's a few games man 2023 is packed
so we're in uh February
so I see Gran Turismo 7 for the VR too I
ain't playing none of that VR nonsense
um I'm looking uh we got octopi traveler
in a couple days actually uh the day
after tomorrow
uh we got lightfall on the 28th
uh so that's not this
Tuesday that's next year
uh that's Destiny 2 life off oh okay
okay yeah I'm gonna be on that
unfortunately I'm gonna be on woo long
which uh yeah I may or may not be
playing
yeah
um
it's Game Pass
yeah
uh it's it's gonna be interesting man
I'm very curious to hear God's opinion
on all the games coming out this year uh
five dollars cheaper from cobweb I felt
robbed when I bought the the out Awards
on switch it looked and played terribly
even though uh didn't even look like the
same game uh that that's part of the
issue I have I I want that
doc to be something to do something
um two dollar super trap from flame
August about two on Friday is the real
game of the year just saying I would
actually I would actually play that if
if I had it like right now uh I'm
currently looking for another job I'm
not I can't justify spending seventy
dollars on octopath Traveler as much as
I'd love to play and uh Square Enix uh
they they didn't even asked me if I
wanted to go they're like you good
this is
uh there's a lot so obviously we got the
Legend of Zelda coming out apparently
there's a legend of Heroes coming out
um going on you know there's plenty of
stuff to play you got the dead cells
returned to Castlevania next month
that's going to be interesting you got
The Last of Us Part One for PC coming
out that you got Resident Evil 4
obviously MLB the show next month as
well along with 2K uh WWE 2K 23
there's a lot of stuff and that's just
in March I mean if you look in April you
got Hogwarts coming out for the PS4 and
Xbox One God that's gonna be a horrible
experience uh you got the expansion for
Verizon coming out you got Advance Wars
one and two
um
you got Jedi Survivor April 28th but
that's another one I think that was
pushed to May that's not right following
May yeah which uh I I'm gonna try to get
us uh I'm gonna try on IOP to get an
interview with red fault before that
game comes out uh then you got the
darkest dungeon too
you got endless Dragon you got a Suicide
Squad kill the Justice League you got
that PlayStation thing to tomorrow uh
that to talk about yeah it's pay to play
yeah yeah actually
I'm curious to hear real quick because
we're about to pull out of here but next
couple minutes let's talk about that
state of play because then people are
going to say that we're being too much
if we don't even at least talk about it
it's one hour and 12 minutes what's your
expectations with that
um well they say they're going to talk
about five VR games
and games that's probably 10 minutes of
that thing I don't care about now yeah
um and games from their third party
partners
and Suicide Squad is going to be a big
Focus I would like to see more of that
game
um I mean is I mean it's going to be
what it is bro I'm not expecting
anything they said they're not going to
show anything crazy they told us what
they're going to show so I think it's
gonna be okay I guess I mean if you're
into VR I'm sure you'll be excited to
see
those five games they show maybe there's
a big announcement like I saw a rumor
without my Metal Gear collection or
something I don't know how true that's
going to be but we'll see man but you
know I don't think it's going to be
anything
crazy it's not their showcase
you know and I guess they're going to
have a showcase this year because you
have girls said they are
you know which they probably should
because they damn sure didn't have one
last year so
we'll see what happens man well you know
I I don't think it's going to be
anything special
so you think it's just going to be like
a lot of like fluff
I'm not going to say that I'm gonna say
I mean I'm just going by what
PlayStation said five VR games
and titles for my third party and so at
a big emphasis on suicide squad
so I am excited to see Suicide Squad I'm
more of Suicide Squad
yeah and clearly they got the marketing
rights to to them
uh you know Microsoft needs to do a
better job in getting these marketing
rights I feel like they're missing out
on like some of the biggest games on
marketing rights I don't think Justice
League is gonna like do numbers numbers
like that yeah but I do think that it is
a good game to have marketing rights too
and well you know they need to do a
better job on that I think that you
might see some
some indie games that people like I
think you might see some some Japan
games coming in here some salt Square
Enix maybe uh the release date for Final
Fantasy uh pixel uh collection I think I
don't know if that's a release date or
not uh but I think you might see
something like that I'm just curious on
exactly you know why they haven't did
their first party showing like a
full-blown we're showing you everything
coming out for our platform in the next
few years like because this isn't like
Sony Sony has no problem coming out
there and say this is what's coming out
you know what I'm saying but I think
here recently they're they're kind of
like shying away from that like they
don't want to do that anymore
I think it's pretty obvious man
there there's nothing righty
like listen I'm not gonna be a bot
PlayStation has definitely had more
exclusive first party exclusives this
generation than Xbox absolutely
absolutely yeah but I think a lot of
that you can put on the shoulders of
having smaller IPS well you know you can
get you know those kind of projects out
more and that's not necessarily anyone's
fault I think in development last
generation I mean you know yeah of
course yeah Microsoft needs to do better
in General on stuff like that uh we got
a two dollar super trap from flame uh
he's saying let me make sure there's
nothing above that I felt robbed yeah I
already read that two dollar Superstar
from flame octopower octopath two on
Friday the real game yeah I already said
that uh then we got a two dollar Super
Chat from
uh Nintendo Dawn the otaku the only one
that matters is tears of the Kingdom
and then you got a two dollar super
truck from Randy G octopath traveler two
is seventy dollars uh score Enix is on
serious drugs uh flame says it's 60. and
I I'm willing to put uh Flames knowledge
on that particular game more than my own
uh so I I think it is it's it's it's
sixty dollars but even when you look at
a game like that and I know that you
shouldn't judge a game off of the
criterias and how it looks but I look at
something like that and I do think that
okay is this game worth sixty dollars
you know occupied traveler too and I
know it still took a lot of time into
that but
I feel like there's an issue in the
industry on pricing games not every game
needs to be sixty dollars and I feel
like it would sell better if it wasn't
right I and I look at something like
awkward traveler too and I'm like
for ten dollars more I could buy God of
War
if I didn't have it right and to me when
you price yourself at that type of price
who are you really helping
because you're gonna have a bunch of
people look what's coming out Hogwarts
Legacy uh you know you probably got
Starfield in the next couple months
redfall in the next couple months like
why are you pricing your stuff at 60
because at that point when you get sixty
dollars you start being compared to
sixty seventy dollar games and a game on
occupied traveler too even though that I
think it's it's going to be a fantastic
game
would you want that being compared if
you were making it to a 60 70 game right
yeah you know it's just some food for
thought I think forty dollars I think
that game would sell better in general
but Square Enix they like that money and
if they can get for a gift for it but I
we saw octopi Travelers sold very well
on the switch because it was one of his
like founding release titles that's not
the case there
you're gonna have to go out there
and and stand on your own merits and
sell and I just I don't see it doing it
I just don't
we have been all over the place the past
30 minutes all right so that's that's
pretty much all my PlayStation
predictions you know we're just they
they're gonna give us games that we
enjoy and I don't think it's gonna be
anything bad but I don't expect it it's
gonna be serious either no I don't
expect anything to say I think it's
gonna be fine I think it's gonna be fine
so
we we are at the end of the show you
know I'm going to start putting the the
ending of the show time stamps I've had
some people message me over there
um yeah I usually do that ending on the
show yeah so
Dart what's going on with you man what
what what you got going on for people to
do uh not too much man I dropped a video
earlier talking about the red dragon
yeah he's out he's on Twitter tripping
right now
uh you know you know check out my latest
episode of wbg
last Monday we had a lot of fun I also
did a um I like to call it one man dark
man podcast when it's just me I go out
there I do about an hour hour and a half
just you know just me by myself I did
that yesterday so I'll check it out guys
let me
of course put my
you you should have an intro for that
podcast where you're sitting there with
like a uh like
imagine like you know those director
seats
and there's a director seat for everyone
and you you come in and you sit down you
look around you're like I guess it's
just me and it goes to the show
I like that it's just me
yeah but definitely uh it's payment man
what is that good enough I'll be doing
it on my phone so I don't know I can't
spam it as much I will spam it if you
can't do it
I'm gonna have to my computer running
real slow here lately
thank you sir
go on there and follow me man we we
close he close to uh to ten thousand
right is that what you said no no I just
got the eight oh so I still got a couple
more thousand to get but I hopefully you
know I should get it before the end of
the year hopefully got to get you up to
that that ten thousand man yeah man I
don't like once you hit 10 000
um I ain't hit that on my personal
YouTube channel which it's a lot my
fault I need to be more consistent on
there that's that's on me yeah because
you don't do a lot of content on there
bro I I used to but it's just like here
recently there's just so much stuff
going on and I feel like
I feel like there's only enough room for
like one thing
uh so you know I'm gonna I think next
week I'm gonna start up the content drip
there again I probably do like try two
videos a week I think that's gonna be my
goal here's my channel guys if you want
to go over there and sub to it yeah yeah
sub the attic y'all I actually never
really
uh promote my personal YouTube channel
that's my personal YouTube channel over
there and sub to that I appreciate it
for coming through we add up to like 300
like 10 people at once uh you guys come
here every week uh IOP this week you
know uh I don't think we're having a
guest
I I think
so uh next is addict don't even don't
want the work not even timestamps I
think okay look I review games it takes
a lot of time
I do everything on patreon I do all the
Social Media stuff for IOP that takes
time
I do all the shorts for the podcast so
anything goes on Tick Tock anything goes
on uh shorts I do that too
I do a lot of the thumbnails that's not
IOP for the podcast
but I direct all of the community events
and anything like that
uh so look like my IOP keeps me busy
enough and I think I'm gonna have to
just start being like logistic and just
start doing stuff as easy as I can do it
but I appreciate you ever come through
we're gonna go ahead and head out of
here uh we'll see you next week you know
definitely follow me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP Lord addict IOP I'm trying to
get to 5 000 followers on there man
trying to get to 5 000. I'm still a
little bit away but I'm trying to get to
5 000.
um I'm like 900 away but that's fine
that's not bad at all really but I
appreciate you ever coming through and
we'll see you next week peace until next
time this addict